remember that if you would like to chat
with me your uh nickname in the waiting
Lobby on Discord needs to be your name
and where you are calling from your name
and where you're calling from and like
obvious nicknames and jokes just get
skipped just so people understand that
that's an important consideration I
think to keep in mind uh okay let's try
again with Nate from Rhode Island to see
if the technical issues have abated Nate
are you with us now
absolutely how's it going David it's
going well
so I want to elaborate on a previous
call I had so now that we have 51 seats
we can start our own investigations we
can Fast Track judges that that part I'm
especially excited for good
um now I don't know if Biden is for
pecking the Supreme Court I'm pretty
sure he said or expanding I should say
but I'm pretty sure he's not so he
doesn't really have too much hope there
yeah I didn't think so yep
um and also I'm pretty excited with how
fast the special counsel's been working
he's been working daily I mean indeed
yeah I appreciate it yeah
um hey other than that that's about all
I had to say I got a driving lesson
today so wish me luck there wait so
you're you're teaching or you're
receiving you're learning to drive uh
learning to drive through AAA really how
old a guy are you I'm 23 so I'm a little
on the a little older but not too old
and what is it about why you know I so
many people are so eager to get their
driver's licenses as soon as possible
but I know things have changed from when
I was 16 what made you wait years and
years before doing this
very good question thank you yeah so
I've really just never needed to take
driving lessons I've had parents that
have been able to drive me around so
I've just never really needed it yeah
and the situation has changed a bit so
now I'm like hey so I'll take up driving
lessons now and it was never appealing
to say like well even if I mostly don't
need to drive it'd be great to be able
to rent a car if I needed one or it just
never it never was appealing until now
it's not that I was never appealing it's
just that I never really needed to you
know you didn't need it interesting do
you find that you are
well I guess you can't say because you
didn't drive at 16 but I'm wondering
like if you my mom started driving a lot
later than a lot of people and she like
doesn't drive on the highway and doesn't
like driving fast she's definitely like
more tentative do you find that to some
degree maybe compared to other drivers
you know
I was so careful that I had the my last
lesson had to be told to speed it up a
little bit so interesting pretty careful
yeah interesting interesting all right
well Nate listen I hope the lesson goes
well and you have your license before we
know it hey thank you very much I wrote
test is scheduled for March 1st hoping
for the best there beautiful all right
there is Nate from Rhode Island learning
to drive you love to see it I love to
see people develop skills it's a really
great thing